Freunde herzlich willkommen in Hamburg
eine wirklich wunderschöne Stadt die mir
noch mal aufgefallen ist und es soll
hier mindestens genauso gutes Essen
geben ihr habt mich bombardiert mit
Empfehlung ich habe wirklich glaube ich
in keiner Stadt so viele bekommen wie
hier habe mich daran gewagt das ganze
ein bisschen zu sortieren habe fünf sehr
gute Restaurants herausgefunden die
werden wir jetzt testen und wir starten
mit einem Burger los geht's
[Musik]
so Freunde das ist ja also der durchs
Burger und ich muss sagen es sieht schon
mal anders aus als ich kenne wir haben
hier einen Champignon Burger habe ich so
noch nie irgendwo bekommen das war aber
die geheim Empfehlung der Kenner deshalb
mussten wir das auf jeden Fall mal
ausprobieren das sieht schon mal super
juice hier aus guck mal hier das tropft
einfach ohne dass ich irgendwas mache
tropft das hier so heraus das sieht hart
aus also das scheint schon mal
vielversprechend zu sein ich habe super
lange nicht mehr so einen normalen
Burger gegessen also so Smash Burgers
kommen komplett mein mein Leben
übernommen deshalb freue ich mich jetzt
gerade darauf oder wird mit Sicherheit
nicht zu Unrecht so gefeiert und beliebt
sein wenn man so ein klassischen
mittelschnitt hier durch die Mitte lach
jetzt mal so wie Erik immer
wir haben gerade Phillip hinter der
Kamera Philipp habt ihr ja das ist schon
mal kurz gesehen erik ist leider nicht
mit auf dem Trip deshalb schreib mal in
die Kommentare wieder Philipp sich
schlägt als Vertretung bitte der kann
das sonst nicht aushalten hier haben wir
auf jeden Fall den Burger und er sieht
unfassbar juicy aus Brioche spannen
komplett selbstgemacht aus also ist
nicht so dieses was man kennt was man im
Supermarkt kaufen besonders
offensichtlich selbst gemacht und mir
läuft so das Wasser angucke deshalb lass
uns probieren
du kriegst wirklich schon eine komplette
umami Keule weil die Champignons die
Pilze haben ja sowieso so viel umami
Geschmack dann noch mit Sojasoße
glasiert angebraten ultra krasse
karamellisierung auf dem Burger Patty
und so ein Soße wird auch nicht gespannt
die haben auch muss man sagen unser
Essen glaube ich in 5 Minuten bekommen
oder so also crazy schnell also wirklich
ich bin sehr positiv überrascht weil es
halt auch so krass schnell ging es auch
nicht jeden besten Gewissens empfehlen
kann Philipp willst du auch mal
probieren und camera du bist heute Erik
Messer und Gabel sind wie immer nur Deko
wenn man Burger ist so wichtig keine
wollte mit Messer und Kabel probieren
oder
[Musik]
wie du gesagt hast ja so eine gute Säure
irgendwie ne ich muss wirklich sagen ein
sehr sehr gelungener Burger es ist so
einer aus der Kategorie so ich so fast
foodic sondern schon eher so Premium
aber trotzdem noch so dass er einem Spaß
macht beim Essen also es gibt ja manche
Burger die fühlen sich an wie sowieso
Bio Burger das ist das auf gar keinen
Fall sondern der knallt richtig aber es
hat auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen mehr
Substanz als man das kennt vielleicht
sehr sehr empfehlenswert wenn ihr einen
guten Burger wollt aber Burger sind
nicht das Einzige was wir auf der Liste
haben würde sagen ab geht's zum nächsten
Spot
[Musik]
eine Sache davon Hamburg ganz bestimmt
nicht fehlen dass es ein
backfischbrötchen und das beste soll es
laut vielen von Euch hier geben bei
Underdogs wir bestellen das ganze wir
probieren das ganze ich freue mich sehr
darauf weil das eine Sache ist die gibt
es nicht in jeder Stadt und deshalb
machen wir doch genau das bestellen wir
uns ein praktisch Brötchen gucken uns
den Laden mal an und lassen uns
hoffentlich schmecken
[Musik]
okay Leute was geht hier bitte ab das
sieht ja wirklich wunderschön aus wenn
ich nicht besser wüsste ne könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass das so Korean Fried
Chicken ist so richtig knuspriges
Hähnchen aber es ist Backfisch das Ding
ist ich weiß gar nicht unbedingt was ein
backfischbrötchen krass macht aber ich
vertraue einfach auf meinen Geschmack ob
das jetzt rein Schallert oder nicht aber
auch die Präsentation ist wirklich super
hübsch na ja gerade gesehen
also dieses diese bread roll ne super
fluffig so ein bisschen die Brioche aber
nicht ganz so weich was ich aber sehr
sehr gut finde weil es gibt so ein
bisschen Stabilität soll der Backfisch
ist super zart innen drin wirklich
knusprig paniert bin vor allem wirklich
einmal auch schön man kann das glaube
ich nicht essen und die dreckig zu
machen aber sehr sehr gut man da drin
bisschen parcourten hat Zwiebeln und es
schmeckt auch so fresh irgendwie wenn du
so denkst an Fischbrötchen das ist so
Fischbrötchen durchgespielt aber auch
echt eine ordentliche Portion ne also
das ist wahrscheinlich das beste
praktisch Brötchen was ich bisher
gegessen habe also weil ich wie gesagt
noch nicht viel gegessen aber das ist
super lecker
aber ich glaube hier in Hamburg ist das
nicht ohne Grund einer der Favoriten
oder das beste praktisch Brötchen die
lovestore müssen wir natürlich auch
probieren also super aus aber ich meine
da ist richtig viel Hunger drauf aber
das kostet auch 30 €, ne das heißt muss
es auch gut schmecken aber ein bisschen
Zitrone drauf ich habe ja in Amerika man
in der lobstory gegessen glaube ich 35 $
gekostet und die war halb so groß
deshalb ihr kriegt man wenigstens noch
was für sein Geld ne wir sind 30 Grad
rein in die Masse wirklich ich liebe das
ja ich glaube ich hatte sogar mal als
ich gegoogelt habe nach Lobster Roll in
Deutschland diesen Laden hier gesehen
vor drei Jahren oder so deshalb
[Musik]
kräftiger Hunger Geschmack diese Mayo
Remoulade mit der frischen Zitrone so
diese Zitrusnote auch ein Schnittlauch
es ist krass und du hast wirklich so bei
einem Biss hast du wirklich so halben
Hunger im Mund so gefühlt deshalb also
es ist wahnsinnig teuer so objektiv 30 €
für so ein Brötchen aber Hunger ist halt
teuer und du kriegst wenigstens super
viel Hunger für dein Geld dann wurde der
freundlicherweise eingeladen aber ich
sage ehrlich würde mir das auch mal
gönnen trotzdem Danke schön an den Laden
aber auch volle Transparenz aber auch
ohne alles würde ich mir mal gönnen also
es war wirklich sehr sehr lecker ich
muss sagen es war kein ganz klassisches
Fischbrötchen aber ich muss sagen es hat
so den Touch von Hamburg ultra lecker
deshalb dicke Empfehlung von mir abgeht
zum nächsten Spot ich bin wirklich ich
mag das sehr gerne muss ich sagen
[Musik]
und Leute kein Spaß die sind überall
ausverkauft es gibt vier Filialen von
dem Laden hier die meinten keine Chance
sie sind um 16:50 Uhr da keine Chance
dann haben die aus dem tiefsten Ecken
des Ladens noch zwei Franzbrötchen
rausgekramt und uns geschenkt so was
passiert uns nicht mal in Köln wir
hatten wir haben nicht irgendwie gefilmt
oder irgendwas das war einfach nur pure
Freundlichkeit und das in Hamburg also
vielleicht stimmen die Vorteile doch
nicht das probieren wir jetzt aber das
lassen wir uns richtig schmecken hier
haben wir das gute Stück ich greife
einmal rein das ist wirklich das war
wahrscheinlich einfach kein
Schönheitspreis mehr gewonnen und
dementsprechend aus dem Verkauf genommen
das ist uns ganz egal also ich habe mich
wirklich sehr gefreut gerade dass sie
uns das gegeben haben und ich habe
glaube ich noch nie einen
ausgezeichnetes oder ein besonders gutes
transportieren gegessen wir haben ja auf
der Unterseite so ein ganz soften Teil
ganz klebrig in der Hand und Hefegebäck
warum sind die Hamburger so verrückt
danach so und warum lohnt es sich
vielleicht sich das holen jetzt bin ich
gespannt
ich wurde gesagt dass die Seite die
Nummer eins weil die wahrscheinlich seit
100 Jahren ihr Franzbrötchen Rezept
haben und un genau ich weiß nicht ob es
ist weil wir durch die ganze Stadt
gefahren sind um das zu essen aber es
schmeckt wirklich sehr sehr sehr gut
ausprobieren mega geil das ist richtig
lecker ich weiß gar nicht so ob es was
also als jemand der das ein zweimal erst
gegessen hat in seinem Leben ist es so
bei so ein bisschen knusprig um super
süß dieser ziemlich Geschmack total
lecker schmeckt fast so ein bisschen
Beine nachtlichtig mit dieser zimtte
also wer was typisch hamburgerisches
essen möchte schaut gleich bei der
kleinen Konditorei vorbei der Standard
hier wirklich mein Herz ist auch erwärmt
weil sie so nett waren wir uns jetzt
einfach geschenkt das war ein kleiner
Einschub den wir zum nächsten Sport ganz
Brötchen kommt auf meine gute Liste
das ist wieder so weit das darf bei kein
food Hotspots fehlen Pizza und auch in
Hamburg haben wir uns eine besondere
Pizza rausgesucht besser gesagt ihr
meine Kommentar Sticker wurde gespamt
mit diesem Laden chill napolitanische
Pizza und er sieht von außen so sehr
Trends für so einen pizzasport und von
drin was ich sehen kann auch sehr sehr
schick das würde ich sagen gehen wir mal
rein zuhören so schön auf Pizza aus und
gucken wie Sie vielleicht im Vergleich
zu Düsseldorf Frankfurt sonst so
abschließt wirklich so oft wie mir das
geschickt wurde muss das eine super
Pizza sein gucken wir mal rein
guckt euch selbst an ich meine es ist
ein wunderschöner Laden sehr sehr
stilvoll eingerichtet genauso bei der
Karte man kriegt nur eine kleine winzige
Karte mit fünf ausgewählten Pizzen das
sind die tagespizzen online gibt es eine
größere Karte ich habe mich nicht für
eine von denen hier entschieden sondern
für die Lukas Pizza und zwar eine Mitte
scharfer Chorizo ich glaube eine sehr
sehr gute Pizza wurde mir auch empfohlen
deshalb bestelle ich die wir gönnen uns
hier rein und es ist wirklich ein rund
um sehr heißer Laden man hat auch das
Gefühl so Adam Bock auf ihren Job und
ich hoffe der Pizzabäcker auch deshalb
gucken wir mal was wir können Pizza
bekommen
ein Kunstwerk danke schön alter Schwede
das kann sich sehen lassen Lukas pikante
heißt diese Pizza und sie riecht auch
pikante also wir haben am Ende gerade
habe ich gesehen noch mal so ein
bisschen Chili das drüber gemacht wir
haben Basilikum in der Mitte sowas es
ist einfach eine sehr sehr schöne Pizza
genauso auch so der getigerte Rand den
ja eine gute napoletanische Pizza
auszeichnet let's go
also die Schärfe wird fantastische
abgemildert von diesem cremigen Murata
die Tomatensoße ist wie sie sein muss
wahrscheinlich so richtig schönes Summer
sano Tomaten einfach nur ein bisschen
mehr Salz und das ist eine verdammt gute
Pizza dazu müssen wir sagen 15 50
stolzer Preis aber das ist halt auch
nicht eine Pizza sondern ein Kunstwerk
in Form von der Pizza wirklich alle
Zutaten schmecken krass der Teig hat so
eine Knusprigkeit bei dem Underdogs z.B
war das also das war typisch Hamburg so
sind dieser Laden hier könnte halt auch
anderswo stehen aber zurecht wurde mir
so viel empfohlen und zu Recht empfehle
ich ihn jedem weiter deine gute Pizza in
Hamburg sucht also ich haue das Ding
jetzt weg philipp ist auch hungrig und
also es könnte einer meiner
Lieblingsplätze sein und wir gehen jetzt
von hier wirklich nur
100 mm weiter zu lokma und das mache ich
nicht weil ich faul bin sondern weil
anscheinend die beiden richtig richtig
guten top Restaurants direkt
nebeneinander sind und um ehrlich zu
sein ich war hier schon mal und es war
krass deshalb lass uns reingehen
türkisches Essen die ganze Bandbreite
große Gastfreundschaft und gutes Essen
schauen wir uns das Ganze an los geht's
[Musik]
also wir haben gerade hingesetzt und
klar so wir sind mit einer Kamera hier
und so aber wir wurden sehr sehr
freundlich empfangen und wir haben
nichts davon bestellt die erinnert euch
gleich ich habe ein Video gedreht ein
Tag essen gehen in der Türkei da wurde
ich auch beladen mit essen wir haben
heute oder mehrfach gesagt bitte gebt
uns nicht so viel essen wir wollen uns
jetzt eine kleine Platte machen mit den
besten Gerichten für eine Person die sie
hier haben ich habe Angst aber schauen
wir mal was kommt
leute das ist bitte
also wir werden jetzt Sorge tragen dass
das alles sinnvollen Zweck zugeführt
wird aber das ist einfach nicht normal
ich habe gelernt ich möchte zu Philipp
so die werden übertreiben aber wir
müssen die reinnehmen weil alle gesagt
haben es ist einer der Top food Spots
aber ich habe zu Recht Angst wir sind
mit den Worten reinkommen bitte über
Frankreich
aus der Küche direkt auf den Tisch das
liegt nicht so ein Durchsatz an Essen
das fliegt hier quasi durch den Laden
philipp hat das ganze gerade gefilmt in
der Küche da ist so ein Hochbetrieb die
ballern alle was ins Zeug hält das
schmeckt man so das ist einfach das
steckt richtig viel Liebe richtig viel
Arbeit drin aber ein bisschen Platz
zwischen den Tomaten ein wenig
liebe diesen groben Pulver dieser
leichte Tomatengeschmack daran so ein
geiler Garpunkt hier drüben haben wir
ein wenig von einem Spieß der zerfällt
schon wenn ich hier probiere was von
zunehmen wir gehen rein
sieht so lecker aus es ist wirklich du
darfst gleich keine Sorge butterweich
saftig knusprige Schicht außen dieser
Holzkohle Geschmack so alles wird ja
aber Holzkohle gemacht und auch einfach
unschlagbar hier drüben so merken es
kommen immer neue Sachen zum Vorschein
hier drüben sind so selbstgemachte
sagen es ist wahnsinnig lecker super
frisch wir wurden mehr als
gastfreundlich empfangen und ich glaube
für all diejenigen die gerne türkisch
essen wollen eine warme Empfehlung als
Anlaufstelle dafür
ich versuche hier mal zu essen was ich
essen kann dann habe ich vielleicht noch
ein paar Worte und dann sehen wir uns
wieder
das war ein Festmahl für mehr als das
nach diesem sehr sehr leckeren Tag in
Hamburg ich bin mir sicher es war für
euch was dabei wenn ihr meinen Hamburg
seid testet einer Läden aus lasst Euch
schmecken ich gehe jetzt schlafen
übrigens wir haben besprochen das essen
was übrig war wird hier an die
Obdachlosen verteil was sehr sehr
korrekt finde deshalb Probs und bis zum
nächsten Video mach's gut ciao
[Musik]